what's up guys i love fried chicken
sandwiches just as much as the next guy
and i've been dying to do this
particular challenge ever since a
certain fried chicken place came out
with their sandwich took the world by
storm took the fast food industry by
storm so i'm gonna do a little
investigating today with today's
challenge but before we begin thank you
squarespace for sponsoring today's video
we'll be talking about them at the end
so make sure to stick around
what's up everybody we are doing a
fried chicken sandwich contest challenge
challenge yes that's what we're doing
what's up everybody today we are doing a
fried chicken
sandwich challenge everyone wants to be
the fried chicken sandwich king
chick-fil-a might have been the
originator of the chicken sandwich but
there are the likes of popeyes now
mcdonald's burger king
and uh today we're gonna figure out who
we think should be crowned
the king but even burger kings being
baldsy and like we have
the chicken king exactly they even call
their sandwich the chicken so we're
gonna do this challenge blindfolded all
right
and uh we're not gonna know what
sandwich is in front of us when we're
eating it before we get started
do you have a favorite already have you
tried all of them i haven't tried
burger king only i've tried kfc
mcdonald's oh mcdonald's all right so
today we're trying popeyes chick-fil-a
mcdonald's burger king and kfc yeah i've
had
burger king mcdonald's or gifts true me
neither but we've had popeyes and
chick-fil-a right
chick-fil-a and which one's your
favorite i like papayas
yeah i think i'm a popeyes guy too do
you think you're gonna be able to tell
the popeye sandwich when it comes out
well i don't know because usually i get
uh chicken sandwiches without mayo all
right you get it drying i get it dry
yeah okay so we ordered uh so tiff my
beautiful wife helped me
uh collect all the sandwiches today went
to all five different places to get the
sandwiches and we ordered it to be
as original as possible so we didn't ask
them to modify
take out any sauces take out the pickles
or anything we wanted
their flagship sandwich so that's what
we're gonna be eating today
yup so yeah i'm ready to get started yes
all right let's go
okay you got it feel it
there it is it's a sandwich it's in my
hands it won't eat the right one this is
a thick sandwich
this is a pretty big sound
you want to take a bite yeah sure all
right let's go all right three two
one
first thoughts i don't know what it is
but i can tell you it is not
popeyes or chick-fil-a feel another
mcdonald's
or burger king because burger king has
this type of
flavor but i don't usually go to burger
king
which makes me think it's mcdonald's
you might be right by burger king kind
of tastes like a whopper like they have
like the sauce the whopper sauce the
mayonnaise or whatever they put in there
at the aerator sorry if i'm making weird
noises in my mouth okay i'm gonna finish
this thing this thing is pretty good
that's pretty good but it ain't popeyes
you know this sleeper contender in here
is kfc could be kfc they had no idea
what the kfc sandwich would smell or
taste like i feel like it tastes like
their chicken
this doesn't taste like their um
original recipe huh
no it doesn't burger king i think burger
king yeah this is the whopper of chicken
sandwiches
this is the chicken that's my boat
burger king
burger king all right clean our pellets
what do you mean yeah
the water um wash out that last chicken
sandwich we're on to the next one
i don't know where i'm putting this this
seems safe oh thanks tip
it's really hard being blindfolded yeah
it's really hot too my eyeballs are like
hot you're
sweating hard that's a good excuse for
crying this is what batman feels like
all the time
i don't want to be batman it's too hot
okay sandwich number two number
[Music]
oh this is two bread oh it's nice and
soft
yeah oh this might be a good one i mean
last one's pretty good but this one
might be better it's really steep
i can't smell it it's a skinny sandwich
yeah see yeah the thickness
matters in terms of sandwiches some
places make it thinner
it's kind of soggy yeah and like it
sounds wet is it
it's really like yeah as you say so it's
hard to break off like i'm trying to
break off like a piece of the chicken
oh bring it up yeah take a bite yeah
okay
three two one oh
[Music]
what do you think okay just chick-fil-a
yeah taste of chick-fil-a chicken
like this nice cozy feeling
it's a little bit it's just a tiny bit
salty and then it's very chicken
this one works really well with the
pickles like the way it's flavored
the pickle is accentuated into the flame
version it's just oh this is so good
this is a good sandwich right here you
like this one better than the last one
definitely this one is i'm about to
finish it yeah i want to finish this one
this would be my last bite i know what
this one is
i agree it has to be chick-fil-a
all right bring me the next one please
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right bring on number three number
three
trace i'm actually getting kind of full
already oh really
the bread's hard man who served bread
this hard
we're in the medieval era
this is a hard sandwich like i can't
really bend it very much
it's already failing on that end yeah
and then i'm trying to feel the chicken
and it's
really hard granted it's you know
we bought this like maybe like 20 30
minutes ago so but still 20 30 minutes
ago should still be good
all right ready three two one
[Music]
i always figured you know like when you
eat pizza it's really hard to mess up
pizza there's good pizza then there's
mediocre pizza mediocre pizza is still
pretty good
i feel that way about fried chicken
sandwiches up until i ate this sandwich
right here
this is disgusting i'm tasting the
batter i have no idea where it's from
but it's terrible
you know me i'm not a picky eater i'll
eat even bathroom this is not good
tastes fake it does taste great made out
of like
random stuff it's like eating play-doh
it's like i'm eating a hot dog it's just
random stuff from pigweeds you're going
for a second bite
i gotta get to the center of this it's a
mystery to me like literally the center
[Music]
okay there is some sauce in the middle
it gets better with the pickle but this
is not a good sandwich
me and the chicken it's not that bad the
more you eat it
no where do you think this is from
definitely kfc
yeah see i want to say mcdonald's if it
was mcdonald's
mcdonald's failed this personally i want
to give kfc the benefit of the doubt
that they can
make a competitive uh to the rest out
their
chicken sandwich like they do chicken
they do fried chicken they're not bad at
fried chicken they got you know a bit of
a scandal with the whole like
genetically mutated chickens back in the
day but other than that
they had a pretty good recipe and i
would figure they would do a pretty
decent sandwich so this is
kfc i'm really really surprised i really
just like the mayo or like whatever
structures on it yeah all right so you
think it's kfc
all right i'm sticking with my guns and
i think it's mcdonald yeah
next one next one please
[Music]
number four i think number four
remember chicken is it always here yeah
oh the
bread is hard i give it the benefit that
it's just been
a while since we bought these chicken
sandwiches yeah
i can't really judge the bread anymore
because the bottom piece is soggy the
top part is really hard
so i guess we can't really base it off
the feel of the sand sandwich we'll
judge it based on the taste of the
sandwich
i guess this is some off-brand i'm just
kidding
off-brand off-brand company maybe threw
in a mystery one
we didn't even know about all right
ready take a bite yep three
two one
[Music]
you have so much chicken in your mouth
all right so this is two in a row or i'm
like we're eating chalkboard
and that's a chalkboard that's it it
meant cardboard the mash is slowing down
this is terrible
right now oh you know what this is a
better sandwich i bit into a part that
didn't have any chicken just batter
and it's so dry there's no sauce either
this one right here is much better than
this one over here oh
i can taste from the batter okay at the
same time anything
yep three two one
this is that signature popeye's taste
yup the batter
the chicken was really good i thought it
was all good i had a
good first bite i bit into this part
that was just like no chicken it was so
misleading that's the best part though
just the bread now that i'm eating it
blindfolded and judging it man popeyes
is salty is it salty to you
no actually it definitely isn't that
good when it's been sitting out for a
while i like it without me
yeah for sure yeah man i'm proud of you
for eating in there though it's not it's
not like it's gonna kill me
so well i think uh figured out which one
we need last
as sorry for lunch which was the last
one well no uh
wait which one was it last week i forgot
the order
or what we already guessed honestly
though eating this popeyes that's been
out
that's not as fresh as the ones from
earlier and just considering
everything i liked sandwich number two
the most which was uh i think
chick-fil-a all right on to the next one
[Music]
please
this sandwich last sandwich bring on the
sandwich
this one feels weird it's got a little
butt crack
it has a line on it it's a thin one
it's a rinky dinky one for all the
sandwiches before that
had bread that was getting hard this one
actually stayed soft
it did props to the company that made
this
take a break yeah three two one
oh couple things that come to mind
immediately
as soon as i bite into it i know why the
bread is still soft
that's a key uh clue and i bite into the
texture of this chicken meat this
chicken texture
is very signature to this place as well
i don't know
where is it mcdonald's mcdonald's that
means i was wrong about them
the really bad ones from kfc no way
let's go i got it right
unless we're wrong about the burrito one
then maybe the burger king one's really
really bad
you can't see it was the first one then
it was like yes all right tastes like
burnt crackers to me the lack of real
chicken meat in here
really kind of like i don't know defeats
the whole purpose well i like it so
mcdonald's sponsored me
uh yeah there's no like spices in here
like there's nothing interesting about
the batter
it's really plain yeah it tastes like um
school cafeteria food if you said this
is this was a school cafeteria
chicken sandwich i would believe it yeah
it's bad
that's bad i thought it was good all
right mcdonald's sponsor him you hear
that ronald
well i wonder what we got wrong and
right true so
let's move on to that let's move on to
the next round conclusion
let's take off the block
i think i got one wrong i didn't know
i'm wrong for sure i got the mcdonald's
one wrong i was like
this has to be mcdonald's it's so bad
and then i eat the mcdonald's like it's
even worse
i think the kfc it won't make up for oh
the bean
between burger king and kfc you think
you got it wrong probably it means i got
two wrong the only ones i actually got
right
might have been the chick-fil-a and pop
ice there's no mistake with those ones
those are so good but honestly i really
felt like i think i'm like chick-fil-a
better than popeyes now after this
challenge
hands down chick-fil-a over popeye's
tomato definitely for me yeah really
yeah i love uh popeye's not gonna lie
that's my go-to but after chick-fil-a
then when you
have it side by side and you eat one and
you eat another you taste the difference
yeah and then you have like a preference
the seasoning and chick-fil-a is just so
much more like interesting that's good
all right
maestro what did we get right and what
did we get
wrong so for the first one you both said
burger king
but it wasn't what that was your
favorite wasn't it
no i loved it didn't you i liked it for
the first one
being the first one we ate i was like
this is pretty good there's no like
gauge of like bad or good yet but it was
good yeah
it was actually kfc you know how i said
earlier that like i'm like kfc should be
making a really good sandwich they make
chicken they should make a pretty good
chicken sandwich that was a pretty good
sandwich they didn't taste anything like
their chicken though
i was getting whips of whopper
mayonnaise flavor
i was so convinced that it was a burger
king
but i guess not that means then that the
two bad ones the ones were
like that that was
the burger king and the mcdonald's so
the second one
you guys said you both said it was
chick-fil-a and you got it right
chick-fil-a is awesome yes close on
sundays though
you my chick-fil-a third one was the
worst of the worst
the one that you wanted a spit bucket
for yes case
you thought it was mcdonald's and isaac
thought it was kfc
but it was actually burger king boo
burger king
get out of the race you guys are
eliminated like you ordered chicken yes
that's the chicken
i like the whopper actually i'm a fan of
burger king in terms of the whopper and
the fries
but man that your king is the fourth one
you guys both said it was popeyes
and it was popeyes yes and i know you
guys cheated because you heard me taking
it out of the only plastic bag
oh that's how you guys thought it was
popeyes nope
i actually i actually was looking for it
to not be a pond buying because i was
like this is dry you know how i fit into
like a blank pocket of like just bread
and
nothing i was like what kind of sandwich
is this and then i have to bite more of
it oh it's
actually really good so i had no idea
what top ice last one you
guys said it was mcdonald's and it was
mcdonald's yes
fake meat fake bread fake everything it
does taste
fake with no sight it does taste big but
no sight
yeah oh no no you can't see it no i said
yeah
that was the worst one in terms of like
pure
being a chicken sandwich but it was a
better
thing than whatever burger king had
like i enjoyed mcdonald's yeah i could
eat the mcdonald's one over the burger
the burger king one
never again i'm surprised how terrible
it was
who gets the crown chick-fil-a
chick-fil-a
second second runner-up popeyes third
uh kfc kfc kfc is a sleeper
don't sleep on it fourth i'd say is
what do we have burger king mcdonald's
mcdonald's
mcdonald's and then fifth is burger king
burger king doesn't
is isn't even worthy on the top five
list yeah
just knock them out like just they're
not even considering the running but
yeah so
apparently church just has a fried
chicken sandwich i don't know about yeah
i
watched it on a youtube video they have
the protein sandwiches oh we should
include
them in this one they're worthy
next time next time there you have it
chick-fil-a is the clear winner for us
yeah don't go to burger king for your
chicken sandwich cravings
if you liked this video and like
challenges comment what you want for
next challenges and we'll agree to them
and we'll end up doing them so hit the
like button and subscribe for more
videos and we'll see you next time
see you next time on tiffin case and
isaac
once again thank you squarespace for
sponsoring today's video what is
squarespace squarespace is a powerful
easy to use platform for you to create
your website with squarespace you can
connect with your audience
send email communication leverage
audience insights and most importantly
generate
revenue if you want to blog squarespace
has powerful blogging tools to help
build the community it can display all
your social media posts all in one place
so that your followers can easily find
them and share them and if you want to
start your own store
squarespace has powerful ecommerce
extensions there's new third-party tools
to help you manage your inventory
promote your products streamline
bookkeeping and ship items all across
the world
go to squarespace.com for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
tiffcase to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain
if i was to start a new business or a
website i would definitely check out
squarespace peace
[Music]
me